happy 2019 reject nation so for this
specific video you see at our patreon
the lowest reward tier is our weekly Q&A
s
or basically throughout the week we take
a question from a patron and then we do
a full video response to it uncut raw
and the last question we did for the
month of December was from our very
first patron ever named house Heisenberg
and for the longest time in saying you
know we'll put her a q and a's that will
choose one once a month to put up on
youtube and i never do that so i decided
we'll start the new year off properly by
honoring that statement with house
heisenberg's I like this one they're
normally not this long as a pretty long
one but yeah I just thought it'd be fun
to share kick off the year with honoring
our very first patron ever enjoy guys
house highs in bed or I almost rolled
that are just for you buddy QA oh
there's so much I have thing is I
remember in like third grade or
something when you first committed to
learning to roll your R's and I just
listened to you walk around super gas
though are there any troll or
mean-spirited comments that you have
received either on YouTube or any social
media that actually made you laugh your
ass off I've seen various youtubers or
even celebrities Kimmel mean tweets
share some hilarious ones and wanted to
know if you had any G you got any mean
tweets I mean you you rile people up on
Twitter sometimes my favorite one I
don't know any specific like I'm gonna
start saving them now because of this
the one I the frequent ones that are
funny are the let's go on YouTube and
dig through the comments
there's several reoccurring ones that
are funny and good not funny but amusing
mm-hm
to me fake reaction is a fun one it's
funny because a reaction is never it
seems like a reaction is hard to some
people just you either react too much or
you know reacted the way they want you
to funny one to me like I've ever run
the hellboy one listen there was some
comment that was like I hate that you
like everything that's funny because
replying back to the Rose I said
something like smartass II like it's
funny because whenever I don't like
something apparently I upset people just
as much because it's like that comment
is so wildly incorrect yeah I know I
don't like everything so I had to do
videos about how what I don't everyone
opinions speaks for your entire mind and
I've learned yeah you're only as good as
your last opinion I've had similar ones
on like horror videos where they're like
you know you been scared of everything
I'm like it's the [ __ ] point the
point in the trailers they're putting
jump scares for you to get cringy it
yeah I mean the way I at least approach
certain reaction the way I approach
reaction videos in general is I'm like
let's just talk about trailers for a
second like if I see a trailer in the
theater I'm a very I'm a good viewer I'm
an appropriate viewer I don't I don't
try to make too much noise I don't try
it like even when I'm watching the
actual movie I drew like every once in a
while there's something in a movie
really get me to really react you know
like up great ever watching that like
Filipino light scene in the trailer was
have responded moment and I remember I
remember even watching Logan and when
when Logan injects himself stays running
in others in the forest I'm right I
cheered Noah cheering the movie yeah I
remember but I do my best to like the
thing is I feel like a lot of us we
contain ourselves when we watch them and
then the cool thing about a reaction
video is it's the god damn it Todd you
pick like the one Muttley like you've
been chilling this whole time and then
we sit down there may be something about
the energy maybe they're like oh the
energies on this room I'll do something
to approach reactions is like I use it
as the time to let out how I'm feeling
what I am normally being polite and
reserving yeah it's the freeze you let
down the the checker that the new fields
all those little reactions and
suppresses them like when I watch a
horror movie in two feeders I tried not
to
weirdly when I'm watching a movie I'm
trying not to get scared because I'm
like you know so yeah that's appropriate
there they judge your facial expressions
I find that funny I I only watch the
[Laughter]
Australians comments on the bus trailer
are so funny because some of them are
like they go who's the best reaction and
that other people are like what's wrong
with your face
I thought it was a good reaction because
it got a lot of reactions and there are
certain people you're super dude in
there yes moving your face too much
you're right it's that scary alright
it's like yeah we get it scary not that
I mean like like what do you want my
reaction well that that video anytime I
do a solo video inevitably there's a lot
of comments about like where's gray and
and every now and again somebody will
phrase that in a way I find really
amusing and somebody I can't remember
what they said on the video but it was
something about like Greg Lee seems like
for a couple hours
John sneaks into the apartment sets up
camp starts recording video and my god
things like that I've like the whimsical
like dig it's so weird to just see John
in a video must mean something strange
is happening like that's a frequent
comment I like I like I like when people
call is if there's a girl on video and
people are like so outs you just you
have a girl here only to get views yeah
wait a minute let's let's let's uh let's
examine this common for a second this
this idea of someone doing a video to
get views until he's something different
to get it's like is it the point of a
video ultimately to you it's like even
if you as just like a random person with
nothing on your channel puts up a video
I think you probably wants I kind of get
it if there's a product placement I kind
of get it because you're doing a product
placement and when you're doing a
product placement
you're obviously earning money from it
so I like there's a whole argument to be
made there they're wrong like well guys
it's not like [ __ ] YouTube is paying
us thousands of dollars per video or
something like that it's not the product
list is even like a quarter of a
thousand like it's the product
placements like there's a whole I don't
I really feel like I need to explain it
here especially I feel like it's a crock
places a product placement you know and
it helps that all go source helping us
keep doing what we're doing you know but
the idea of you do it just for reviews
I'm like so does every YouTube video the
platforming is that that's the whole
point is to whoever does a video on
YouTube
and goes I was hoping I got no views on
this video I want to start a really
underground YouTube channel where I take
a video down as soon as he gets above
five years people will be like you
brought a girl here just for views and
then if you don't bring a girl for a
week where the girl I mean yeah there's
a sort of contrarian you just can't
please everybody up there's no medium
for everybody yeah well there's also
like I do sometimes people will comment
with things that I'm like oh yeah that's
a good point
I should probably like maintain my hair
better like sometimes people will show
up and then you'll look at the video and
be like oh yeah I see what you're saying
thanks for the tip couple of people
commenting lately on what do you call it
like my beanie yeah like my daredevil
and Punisher one because the thing is I
don't like this like this beanie is the
right size this this Breaking Bad one
it's perfect for your community the
daredevil one that you inverted it's a
Punisher one is so big and I don't like
this look you know where it's like
popping so much out of the top of my
head
and so I I flip it that for some reason
it bothers the [ __ ] out of mobile people
which makes meanie go well now I'm just
gonna keep doing it yeah because I'm not
a slave to someone's hatred over
something very minut is and if it upsets
you that because yesterday oh like
something on the car ride back from
Colorado I was just pondering going who
are these people that not even like a
pop hatred kind of ponder like I'm
annoyed just a very like a very
fascinated curious pondering thing
like who are the people that comment on
like leave hate I don't think one time
I've stumbled across any video in my
life and been like [ __ ] this guy I gotta
let him know shitty he is so that he
never makes another video and I know
that if there's someone who's who's
going to say that about to see one of
our videos or something they'll I know
we're not exclusive to just us I know
they probably hate on other people's
videos and then it makes me go who are
these people how long we must someone be
to get out that level of annoyance or
hatred on a strength like it just makes
no sense it doesn't make no sense to me
and like it's so very lonely human
beings and looking at them in that
perspective me
I'm like the people that I know that are
people who are not lonely a good-hearted
people never waste a minute second to
just leave a bunch of hatred on I never
I never catch a a friend of my being
like hold on a sec I gotta tell this you
how much I hate them for what we do you
know yeah cuz I mean like it's what it's
like William Paul's [ __ ] recording a
dead hung body and making fun I'm like I
I kind of get that before we or even I
mean not that it makes it right but even
if we were out here like espousing
political opinions and discourse like
all the time you know like really riling
up hot-button issues or something like I
might understand it better we're
checking out movie trailer watch try not
to laugh at videos like I don't know
check it out TVs we can do a 12-minute
video and then we could still take a
little crack about Trump and then
there's guaranteed someone who's like
unsub I came to this channel for movie
talk not to not to become a political
champ up like we made one slight
reference even out of 12 minutes if we
spent a minute
riffing entre that doesn't mean more a
political we don't evolve into the Young
Turks want to be just because of that
you know yeah like I'm always fascinated
that there seems to be like a trumpet
roll or something like that catch like
you you never throw one out and it
doesn't get caught by some I think a lot
of like especially troll hate comment it
the ones that surprised me them the ones
that like I could be kind of
understanding if you're so mad and
you're watching the video then you leave
a comment on that video you're watching
because you have them the second to do
it but when you go to my Twitter or you
go to my Facebook or Instagram page just
because you did not like something in a
video and you have to go out of your way
to go to a separate application or
website to send me your personal [ __ ]
patron opinion oh man the amount of you
have no you got nothing else better and
you are lonely and sad there's no other
definition I could possibly apply to you
for that moment because because people
will take to Facebook and write you like
wow and they'll jump on it like we did a
Captain Marvel video just recently and
somebody jumped on was like oh you guys
do we talk about [ __ ] about one not
everything is about [ __ ] Marvel and
to you guys all you do is [ __ ] on DC and
and don't he skipped two and then just
went straight to three and it was one of
those things where I was like is course
this is about Mars Captain Marvel this
is about Marvel like like the even the
low lapses and logic becomes so
ridiculous and it's clear that people
are just mad because the second you
respond the tone changes like yeah and
if you receive your
calm enough then this I learned this in
social media is like people say all
kinds of terrible things and if you
respond in a way that suggests you're
not gonna just take that but you're also
not going to be a dick about it either
yeah people will open right up and be
like oh I'm so sorry you know I just you
know I just really wish through this
yeah personally experience it firsthand
with like some guys dick I reply to them
with a lot of logic that's one of those
things too is I think a lot of people do
get lonely and and do kind of want a way
to get those feelings out but also I
think people just don't think I think
there's a weird aspect of assuming that
people won't read them and then it
doesn't matter because yeah like once
you break the wall and you start
interacting with things change really
fast well the issue is the issue that
they have is is is so much deeper than
what we did to actually cause it's
there's something so much deeper rooted
than what we did or said if that caused
that response it's it is you know it's
like I've heard there's like Tony
Robbins audio recently I was talking
about like like these six human needs
and and often times there's this thing
he defines it's called a crazy eight
where if you lash out and anger a lot of
times that's that's fulfilling this need
for significance or need for certainty
or whatever and bottom line a whole
conversation about it it's it's not I
just from taking enough space away from
comments I've been able to go this isn't
me yeah there's something so much deeper
seated and this person would honestly
probably not treat me this way in person
or over a telephone even you know if
they were actually interacting with me
yeah it wasn't so much between us and if
they weren't breaking down like a
singular moment out of my life that's
frozen I know this because man I a phone
call or in person argument with Greg
haha can be wildly different that a text
argument with Craig
because when I'm texting and if I'm an
in-text argument I can that's that like
III one of my biggest faults that I've
gotten better at for sure but I still
notice I'll be like oh yeah we carried
away I'm a total dick right now I'll go
back and delete that Hey look there's a
new comment here I like John Gregg not
so much oh no oh that's the other thing
too is that everybody everybody thinks
you're stoned all the time that's a
comment that comes in constantly no
matter what you're doing no matter what
the video is it always thinks that your
stone and it's harder to take like
reading that like my initial reaction is
like oh that's a bummer that hurts my
feelings yeah and the second I started
to feel bad I'm like there are some
people who watch this channel hate me
just like hate John preferred me as you
people who don't like me prefer John
we've crossed that bridge a long time
ago the other and I think like John
pointed out something funny I mean it's
not so true as a guest I bring on often
cat Alvarado and and we did this
Bilborough reaction and if there's
anyone who I love cat because cats
always honest no matter what goes down
she's very honest person and a lot of
people love her would love her for that
yeah and if it's a video where her
opinion is in unison with the majority
he then say okay there were little
Lobster bring her back she's hot she's
funny whatever but then when she doesn't
oh don't bring her back yeah her son son
Drake know people get sued they've
talked to you a great message about it
and and there was and I'm never gonna
stop reading Catalan I love her she's
amazing happy and you need a little bit
at controverse so there's this bill burr
video where cat had a difference of
opinion about the bill burr or stand-up
and she wasn't even hating on and she
was just talking about the time
shame blah blah blah and of course
everyone reacts to her and not everyone
but a lot of people did react to her in
a very like negative way and she said
need something done perfectly about like
it's I've never seen so many people
behave so over sensitively wall accusing
other people being so oversensitive yeah
and it's weird cause like stand-up
comedy in particular breeds this
argument so hard where people will come
in and be like all of these [ __ ]
oversensitive snowflakes are killing my
favorite art form and I'm like you still
exist and you sound ridiculous right
yeah you sound so much and the people
who agree with cat in that comment
thread are usually just like I don't
know I mean if you watch the video she
says it's not a bad joke yeah most
people click off like someone comments
it on there start us out for bumblebee
like it wait and I watched the video the
bumblebee review and in the first 30
seconds were being sarcastic yeah we're
being like just so obviously sarcastic
I'm like you went off at that and
probably stop watching and I are
commenting here because our opinion did
not fulfill the opinion you wanted to
hear that you can be so reactionary as
to go OK I just heard an opinion I don't
like I'm gonna leave that I've gotten so
stupid so yeah you know it's like does
it affect me in the moment
I hate commenting that affected me
because you always want people like
whatever you make you know as long
people you know it's like why we do this
too is for to get some views
yeah people liked it I saw I did that
comment this is a guy said you yet you
did review and start us and said you
loved it oh my god into that's on
YouTube
you clearly don't watch the whole video
is that stupid that's a stupid thing so
anyway yeah like I I actually heard a
Jim Carrey audio recently where he was
saying your your your need for
acceptance can often lead you to become
invisible in this world so it's this
constant battle of it's like you want to
make sure you're being true to yourself
you want people to like you but you
don't want to strive for people to like
it's weird about getting like grab a kid
no that's the bottom line the internet
you're never going to achieve it so
might as well not try to know all you
the best you can hope for is that more
people like you than they don't you
could literally rescue a baby from a
burning building and you will get
someone to hate you [ __ ] crazy genius
of the year over here
figuring out the secret anyway thanks
House Heisenberg saved you you were the
one the first questions to come in will
be saved you for last buddy
first patron ever house eisenbergers
patient the last question the yeah much
love